thank you the red rock legacy bicycle  trail is moving forward it will connect  summerlin and the red rock visitor  center local non-profit group save red  rock has been pushing for the trail for  more than a decade now clark county  commissioners approved 14.7 million  dollars for the trail and save redrock  says they're excited about the path and  the positive changes it will bring to  that area coming up next we really  really want to provide people especially  new people to cycling a place to ride  where they don't have to fight for their  lives with cars  it was back in 2005 metro police officer  don albeets was killed riding his bike  in that area the tragedy inspired the  community to develop safer conditions  for cyclists  and